there is no minimalist rule book
well until now the minimalists have
created
16 rules for living with less
a free ebook which you can download
right now
at theminimalists.com resources enjoy
minimalists
here's what celebrity wants to know how
do i stop my impulse to buy
multiples of items that tend to wear out
quickly
backpacks water bottles etc
there are some things that simply seem
to warrant
a backup uh i have um
i want to say staley you're buying the
wrong backpack and water bottle i've had
the same water bottle for
five years i've had the same backpack
for
well i got the new pack to backpack yeah
but that thing i took camping
in like that this was not last week the
weekend before
um it was just very durable i could sit
here and tell you about all the dirt and
scraping up against rocks and like it
falling off the side of this mountain
and you know it was really durable so
uh that would be my advice to slay lee
is
you know don't forsake the
uh the quality for the quantity because
if you
spend a little bit extra up front and
get a high quality product you don't
have to buy multiples now there are
multiples of things i buy like toilet
paper rolls yes
um oh i don't do this anymore because i
finally got a good
set of uh like slip-on flip-flops
um thanks to rich roll i won't tell you
the brand because they're not paying us
and the brand for me isn't the best for
them but
rich roll helped me out with this like
really good pair of like
leather uh flip-flops that
i can see like oh these are gonna last a
while but i used to get
the havanas and i'd buy two pair at a
time because
and they always break the most yeah the
worst times man like
we're walking around have you been to uh
the oh man the getty villa
yeah yeah so i haven't been to the villa
just the getty okay so the villa
uh i mean you know you've got to walk
around a lot both but like
mariah's uh havana's broke the getty
villa and like i got a paperclip and
somehow i don't even know how i did it
but like got a paper clip and somehow
like
rigged it up for her to like finish
walking you're like the generic macgyver
yeah exactly but uh we went home we had
another pair so like she had another
pair to like go to the beach the next
day
sure um so there are there are doubles
but
when i saw how wasteful it was with
those flip-flops i'm like okay i need a
better solution i didn't really
have one until rich roll kind of kindly
introduced me to these
this and where i got a pair of them as
well but uh but yeah so
all that to say is like yes there are
some things that i will buy multiples of
but if i find myself
being wasteful like then i start to look
for a better
substitute yeah i think i would identify
whether or not i'm making an excuse
right because i hear some sort of
excuses in this question
because the reason i say that is the
examples that have
that were proffered here they as you
mentioned are not great examples like
you can buy a backpack that you know
patagonia makes phenomenal
becks has the same patagonia backpack
for like i think 17 years yeah ever
since she
before she got out of college yeah right
and so
she she's had that for a really long
time uh the same with her the boots that
she
she just replaced her what are those
toughs i think they're called
anyway no i'm kidding
she she had for like 15 years and they
finally wore out
and so there are high quality items of
course buy once
let's put a link to that in the show
notes sean so
they recommend products and services
that you know are
everlasting your the idea is to buy
something once so that it
lasts a long time or even a lifetime
yeah and so
keeping that in mind but ryan is correct
as well there are some things that you
buy just for win
so i like to delineate they're just in
case
they're emergency items and there is
just for win those are three of our
rules from the minimalist rule book
right
so the just in case items are things
that we justify holding on to and
i hear a little bit of that in slayley's
question here yes yeah i'm going to buy
this
just in case well if that's the case i
wouldn't buy it and i wouldn't hold on
to it if it's a just in case
just in case unless it's one of those
rare emergency items it's a just the
case item
so i have a first aid kit at home
hopefully i don't have to use it within
the next 90 days so it doesn't fit in
the 90 90 rule it's
but it is just a case item i don't i'm
not i don't hold it just for when i'm
going to use it
it is just in case i need it snow snow
chains when we lived in montana where
just just in case emergency item right
and so a handful of emergency items that
are appropriate for me
depending on my circumstance those are
important those are those are just in
case items that
i can feel good about they actually
bring peace of mind
to my life right but we have to be
careful because we can justify anything
as i hear in the question
then finally we have the just for win
rule just for win is as ryan says i
don't buy my
toilet paper one square at a time my
toothpaste one nerdle at a time
i will buy in fact with toothpaste i buy
four tubes of toothpaste at once
every time you're gonna say four nurdles
i have three in my pocket right now
toothpastenerds.com
like the the uh hash browns or the tater
tots in my
cargo shorts yeah um i feel like i'll be
doing the same thing with uh
with nurdles of toothpaste anyway uh i
buy
four tubes of toothpaste just for wind
because i don't like going to the
grocery store
a lot and so and when i get down to zero
tubes i go buy four more
that's just how i do it i know i'm going
to use it every time
so it is just for win yeah i bought the
double pet
mariah and i buy the double pack and
like when that when we get down to the
first
or to the last one it's like we put it
on our list
and then we'll go get another double
pack yeah anyway
that makes sense and so uh what you're
talking about is setting up some
boundaries there
yeah and just for women is is a type of
boundary
emergency items or is an understanding
that sometimes
unfortunate things happen we can prepare
for some of those
the most likely ones we certainly can't
prepare for everything
not an advocate for prepping in fact i
think that prepping can disconnect us
from a community we did a whole episode
on
on prepping with tk coleman you can go
back and listen
to that episode and then of course the
just in case items
if you're really holding on to something
just in case here's your permission
let it go just let it go